I'm O I'm Joey. I'm Sasha. Um,
and I'm Danny and we've been dating for a little over two months now.
Yeah. Why do they look like siblings? Sometimes couples look alike.
How always fond that whole phenomenon. Really weird.
Even this couple looks alike. Yep. Sometimes it happens.
They're gonna have some trait. Oftentimes I Don what the percentage is of that,
of how often that happens. But I know that that does happen.
And I've seen people that I know they go out with people that look like them,
aesthetically, they look like I'm like, that could be your sister. You know,
they say incest is incest. Who the says that?
Uh, you never seen them hold up. And, and, and there's places,
your cousin is a win. Okay. Yeah. Alabama and all that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Respect other cultures, respect other cultures. They say, they say, uh,
blood is thick than water. <laugh>
<laugh> I even know what that means.
You know, make what you said, but blood is thick in water and like,
it's just the system of a dude, like I'm thick. All right, come get this.
But it B and you just got married, clean. He gonna get,
and you just got married in the back. It's a family. A
cause you know, Mary J Blage would definitely do an incest commercial.
She did a, she did a chicken commercial for no, no,
we can't play that. Play that.
It exciting things are happening at burger king. Welcome.
To burger king. Oh, what's in those new chicken snack wrap.
What's in the new chicken. What's in the new chicken wrap. Mary
crispy chicken for three fresh dress
and breath. Tasty
Toga, crispy chicken.
The new chicken snack wrap. Come and get it at burger king.
Talk. Is this,
is this the most ringy as commercial
bro? Crispy chicken. God.
All right, let's go. Do you guys.
Know each other's passwords to your phone? Your laptop? No, absolutely not.
What do you guys keep from each other? Nothing. <laugh>.
She said nothing. And the first thing he went, he grabbed his cap. <laugh>
he didn't even know that's a thing. What do you guys keep from each.
Other? Nothing.
She said say boring. She said nothing. Like she was hiding something.
So were you hid from each other? Nothing. See,
yeah. Yeah. She said that. Like her papers are about to run out. We are kind of.
Well, we don't have secrets between us. Yeah. That's.
True. I don't even understand that. What does that mean?
When couples say they don't have secrets between us?
Like there's gotta be sift that you guys keep from each other. No.
There's some people that don't some people that talk about everything.
Let me ask you something. If your friend tells you a secret,
does that mean that your couple is to know for some people? Yes.
For some people? No. Oh, that's weird. Yeah. There's some people that, yeah,
they people that go ahead and say everything.
So today you guys are gonna be going through each other's phones and laptops.
I mean, I'm not too worried. I have nothing to hide. We'll see.
About that. Oh my gosh.
Good luck.
Oh, this picture of, um, his Dick.
<Laugh> who's he sending that to his ex-girlfriend probably what's the next
juicy one you wanna look at?
I wanna go to his Instagram DMS. Okay. There's a girl. She said,
hi bibe. I left my keys. There.
<Laugh> is that some one he slept with?
I have no idea. This is somebody's.
I don't know who it is. There's one of her in her bra.
Someone I used to hook up with. He says, it's someone he used to hook up with.
Oh God, Joey.
<Laugh>
your last is everything. <laugh>.
Post you've liked. Uh, I don't know who this is.
Uhoh Figoni oh, that's my friend. She says that's her friend. Oh,
good looking friend. I'll have her explain that. When she gets home,
does she have any DMS? Don't know what.
That is. <laugh> <laugh>.
She's laughing. She must have something to hide. Nothing.
I don't have anything to hide.
The more she talks, the more suspicious. She sounds. Yo,
she sounds like someone who's avoiding deportation.
Like ice is around the corner. No, I have nothing. I have nothing too high. No,
no. I have nothing. I promise. Meanwhile,
she's got a whole Filipino family in the back.
What? There's a video of him throwing up after drinking too much.
And that makes me sad. I didn't know Joey, when he was drinking,
I've only known him sober. So this is hardest personality that I haven't seen.
Does it scare you to see his old self? Um, yeah.
If you had known him then would you be with him now?
Probably not.
God. This show's intense. I don't know if it's the editing,
but that reaction looks gut rich and didn't it. Yep.
I imagine it's gotta be scary to hear that.
Only because if you were really like an addict,
if you really had a problem that scares you to know somebody would leave you.
If you would fall back into that is a very frightening prospect.
You can look at old snaps. You wanna see what he's saved? <laugh> oh.
No. Hey man. Shout out to the producers. Always stay messy, bro.
I never seen this place, but I know there's underwear hanging from the ceiling.
This man's not play. This man is mud personified. I see.
Some from his ex.
<Laugh>. No.
Oh my God. These are really long messages. Oh my God.
I think this is them breaking.
Up. Watch. He's gonna say, read that out loud guarantee. Read that. No
<laugh> going in having a field trip.
He's having a field trip. He's having a field trip. I,
I know what his mindset is. AE. He's the money.
So all you think about is like drama. So it's funny to watch. She.
Says I'm tired of every single guy I talk to. You're suspicious of.
Cause she cheated on me. Why wouldn't I.
<Laugh>
this man is still pressed about what hap of course I'm gonna ask her.
The cheated on me. Like of course he's he he's no,
but he's acting in real time as if she just said it and he's like, you dumb.
Of course I'm gonna, you cheated. You know? You know what? This was.
This hand gesture was who? That's what it was.
Of course she cheated on me. Yeah. <laugh> I, I, I,
I can understand why it was just funny. It ended.
With her saying, sorry for texting this,
but it doesn't look like are going to talk anytime soon I've been saying I felt
distant and wanna talk to you and you haven't done.
My heart 14,000 photos. Oh gosh.
She says so many pictures. Oh, I found her ex and I'm kissing.
Oh God. Why do you still have all these photos? Oh my gosh.
Him in his underwear. <laugh> oh,
I just found the DMS to Elliot her ex-boyfriend he said you're freaking hot.
<laugh> I'm a demon picture of my face. <laugh>.
<Laugh>
that's a little flex.
That's a flex that's <laugh> that's a flex. Nah,
she with me now Nier what's up.
<laugh> if it was me, I wouldn't even show my face.
I would just record and I would just be like off screen going. Like.
That's a lot of videos.
He's pressed. Yeah. Yeah. A hundred percent. I could already tell.
He's gonna be the main storyline today. How do you feel about her holding.
Onto texts and photos from her ex I don't understood it personally because I go
back and like, look at stuff. If it's there.
I like purge like everything about the relationship. Like as soon as possible.
Oh, I found the pictures of them in bed together.
Oh God. Did she talk about her ex a lot? Uh, no, not at all actually.
Did you love him?
What'd she say?
I'm not gonna say go ahead and get up.
This was a, it is a whole mess.
This a whole mess in a train wreck in a dumpster
fire in a car crash and a whole together in the
year 2020. This <laugh> is the whole. Oh,
this producer. Wow. But he knows what the is doing. 9 million view.
Why do these two look like bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton after he got his
Dick set. And funny enough,
the one that got his Dick suck is not the one that you think <laugh>.
How was that for you guys? Stressful. So, uh,
why do you keep all those photos of your ex? A lot of.
Them are just good memories that I really just don't wanna delete, to be honest.
Why do you care?
Okay, so I'm not gonna rail on her.
Cause I think at the moment she's feeling bad because he feels some type way,
you know,
having pictures of your ex or this or that doesn't mean mean that there's
something weird and sessions going on.
Sometimes he just keeps the of stuff and you really think it's innocuous,
not recognizing it might make the other person uncomfortable.
So her seeing him uncomfortable,
she's being slightly inconsiderate in the moment,
but it's also happening right then and there, you know what I'm saying?
Like if someone comes at you right then and there,
you may not have always the best reaction. So, you know, I'm a,
I'm gonna not say too much about it. Mm-hmm <affirmative> what do you think?
Not much of it. I don't care personally. No. I'm like I'm,
I'm I'm not a jealous type at all. Yeah. I mean, to me,
I could find a whole box of pictures of my girl with her
ex I'm I'm with her.
So like that doesn't that doesn't you're with her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But you know what I would say though,
he did get cheated on. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's a bit more of a tender spot for him. Yeah.
And I think she does have to be a little bit considerate about that portion,
but yeah, he sees, might see a pattern where there's no pattern. We don't know,
but yeah. That's the reason why you got, why, why do you care so much?
Why do I care? Yeah. And he's just gonna ask
because of this.
I dunno. It's just seems like you're reminiscing on the past.
I did think this Snapchat was interesting. Yeah. Yeah.
I'd have never seen that before.
I'm glad that it's still logged so we can go through it together later. Yeah.
That's.
True. Can some things be private between you? Yeah. Yeah. I'd say so.
<affirmative>.
I mean, we just, it's probably healthy to have things that are private. Yeah.
It's just, there's a,
I feel like there's a difference between like privacy and secrecy.
I agree. You guys love each other. Yes, yes. So much.
I still love her. Thank.
God. Yeah. I mean, listen, as far as this whole thing goes,
like my thought process is I get, I get it. It, it is it's tough.
There is no one size fits all.
Some people are not gonna be comfortable that others are.
But I think it's also important to take no note of the effect.
Like what did the other person go through? You know,
if I met somebody and you know,
maybe they went through something that really affected them negatively. Like,
uh, maybe, maybe they got beat before me. Right. Usually get beat.
I have to move different within the confines of that relationship because of how
is what I'm saying, making sense. I see what you're saying.
You have to understand the passive of the person and how,
because of their past they perceived some things. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Like that boy that was, that got cheated on when she asked, why do you care?
Cause he got cheated on and you know, people, so. Yeah, exactly.
So even if I personally don't think there's anything wrong with what she did,
you have to understand who it is that you're dating the same way.
If you are dating a veteran, he got PTSD, you know,
you just can't be making loud bang,
bang noise around the house and then be shocked when they just babe,
just fireworks. Exactly. So just, you know, you have to be considered of like,
of that,
that you have to move different depending on who it is that you're dating and
also understand what their past is like. That probably be the biggest thing.
But overall, that was interesting video anyways, that's it for today's if you.
Hold,
hold.